Justin hey Walt you're here which means
some goddamn stuff happens somewhere in
the video games industry not a lot is
happening yeah it's a slow news week as
we guess we come into III having there's
there's not a lot of a big news it's
gonna be coming up because everyone has
all of these stories that they're
keeping bottled up because if they get
out then those people are gonna get
fired last week Microsoft did a really
bad job of that and they just decided to
talk a whole bunch of massive at halo
hey guess what I will fall yeah yeah I
mean sometimes you need to get those
leaks that come out and then everybody
just talks about all this you like well
we were gonna save this but we might as
well just come out with it now right all
right I I don't think all everything is
always confirmed sometimes story details
or something interesting leaks out there
was a watch far cry 4 story details came
out just recently you know the page was
leaked out so you can read about what
the story is going to be but that's not
official yet even though it was on the
Uplay page yeah so but outside of that
we did hear some interesting stuff this
weekend where Google isn't ol not Google
YouTube isn't talks to buy twitch you
note which is the popular game streaming
service that we use here that right now
hi Tressa what's going on I just as
there you go four games to watch stuff
about games and it's not google that's
buying them I mean Google owns YouTube
but youtube is the one buying them and
that's interesting in both positive and
negative ways I mean it's good that they
are still a start-up they are not a huge
company that just has lots of money to
throw at something light like their
twitch programming there are problems
with twitch it's not the perfect program
there are things that could be done to
make it better yeah then it's not a
great experience in everywhere saying
that there could be a benefit to it
because it's a big company and they can
add you know infrastructure eyes are
like content-wise might be able to
improve what's already there yeah they
can expand and offer features that the
community has been demanding that that
we would like to see in a system like
this but aside on the flip side it it's
YouTube um you know YouTube does a lot
of interesting things I go to youtube
for all my game trailers and that kind
of stuff when I'm not looking at them on
gamespot of course yeah nice work saved
it but youtube is got into a little bit
of trouble with community for you no
copyright infringement and getting
really really quick to just bring the
hammer
on people that are going against what
some of their media partners are doing
and we had all that nintendo stuff that
happened a couple of months ago and i
was all getting pulled they also do a
lot more stuff like Conte region locking
of content or just like cutting out the
audio on a video if it if it goes
against some copy or a possible
copyright it doesn't even have to
necessarily infringe on a copyright if
someone just reports it they can just
cut out the audio and you just have a
kind of useless video and twitch isn't
like the Wild West but there's
definitely streams you watch honor where
people are like just just having fun
just playing their own music just
showing you know content that might
necessarily be theirs and then also I
feel like with the sort of the
continuing conversation about who owns
gameplay footage with the ettes play
stuff and all these youtubers getting
you know their their job essentially is
based on showing off gameplay if Twitter
then involved in that conversation again
then it's like one if YouTube fold on
some of that or Google do then
everything falls on it you know we
really hope that you know YouTube has
learned their lesson from introducing
that Real ID stuff that then when Google
came in and they said well this is gonna
be linked to your google+ account you're
going to use this real name you're gonna
have to sign into Google Plus and
everybody hate I mean that's a terrible
system that didn't work right and it's
still kind of wonky and I'm sure that if
they bought out twitch if this merger
does go through a bit worse orbital
calculations with it oh wow it's but it
isn't there in talks yeah but it's not
it is definitely not set in stone it's
not necessarily going to happen a lot of
things could step in the way in the
meantime but I don't think that they
would come in and just immediately
integrate thats to that same real name
ID system that would just be complete
stupidity and it would make a lot of
people really unhappy it was especially
for streamers I feel like the anonymity
thing as an important part of that for
some anyway and twitch is such a
community-driven thing it's so much
about the people being invested in the
people who are there in the games that
are being played and the the chat
community that there in that you know
you've got to be really careful to not
destabilize any of the pillars of that
community to not shake that up because
then what what if you bought and then
just totally soured so I'm sure that's
on their radars like we got it we got to
get this with white gloves and the other
scary thing is just that YouTube is such
a big behemoth of a creature and I
basically see all of my video on either
you too
or twitch and if twitch buys our YouTube
by stretch then basically I'm seeing all
of that owned by Google no I'm not going
to other places to watch video and then
so if they do something stupid like
introducing that Real ID system that's
going to affect everything that I watch
there's not really an alternative that I
can go to all the eggs are in one basket
it's going to violate all the antitrust
laws you've setup in your living room to
make sure that not one source has a
dominant view of or you know channel to
your mind share well I mean it's at
least two-thirds because they don't
control my porn it means talk about oh
thanks oh yes brazzers.com is next on
youtubes list of acquisitions we got
porn and then Googler knows everything
that I do sorry the hand motions not
meant to be that browsers yup that's
better yep oh you're no better with each
one how do you got look I make a hand
motion without it being something filthy
sit on your hands ah no that's the saga
Oh God oh good Justin hey walls and
thank you very much for coming on